so i've got a couple of pretty horrible
um covid related stories sadly these
aren't fun stories these aren't stories
to make fun of people these are really
stories that are
pitiable stories
but also just another indictment of the
completely backward situation we have in
this country with who people or at least
who some people are willing to trust
when it comes to medical advice and the
way propaganda spreads and
disinformation so let's start with the
first one
new mexico health officials suspect two
people dead from ivermectin poisoning
symbol that's usa today similarly kob
reporting two new mexicans have died of
ivermectin toxicity per state health
officials state health leaders say more
people are taking ivermectin to treat
covid19 in some cases it's been deadly
the new mexico department of health said
two people in new mexico have died from
ivermectin toxicity not much is known
about either patient but one of them was
battling a severe case of covid19 it's a
serious issue we need to watch it says
dr david skrace
uh acting secretary of the new mexico
department of health new mexico health
leaders are sounding the alarm on
ivermectin poison control said there
have been 20 exposures to the drug this
year alone already double the usual
amount
we've had cases of seizures
hallucinations coma you know it can be
very dangerous if you take a high enough
dose
officials say the majority of the
exposures were in the past few weeks
most to treat or prevent covid health
experts say the data just isn't there to
prove it works our medical advisory team
has looked at this three times still
does not feel people should be taking it
and of course the fda has not yet
approved it um ivermectin is almost
exclusively used to treat parasites in
horses and cattle in rare instances
humans same drug different formulation
different dose if you take too much you
go into a coma you may have seizures you
may have hallucinations it's a it's
basically a neurological toxin recent
studies have shown it has some effect on
covid but at a pretty significant cost
when it was combined with standard
therapy it had lower death rate and
progression to severe disease but in
that in vitro study you needed clearly
toxic doses to achieve the effect on
virus replication i think that's an
important detail to mention here we had
that call from a uh biomedical
researcher a couple weeks ago who said
you know you have to understand that
when a study says that in vitro
it kills covid uh particles deactivates
covid whatever term you want to apply
there
in vitro and in vivo are two different
things but the relative dose of what you
can do in vitro
could be completely toxic in humans and
where i continue to go back
is it's really strange to me
not to take something tested
given to billions
and fda approved the pfizer vaccine
and instead take ivermectin i i just
don't get it like even if it's true that
it might be slightly effective for covid
if it's in addition to all the standard
stuff but it can have real side effects
which is dubious but let's imagine
that's the case
um
why accept the cost when we have a
vaccine
that is more effective and i don't know
that we're necessarily going to get an
answer to that right now
uh the usa today article adding a few
other details
um that i wanted to mention
um
the confirmation comes week weeks after
the state suspected one person was
fatally poisoned by ivermectin the
anti-parasitic drug has not been
approved for treatment of viral
illnesses uh such as covet 19 but has
attracted popular advocacy particularly
among skeptics of the vaccines
treatments and public health measures
such as masking in public including
popular podcaster joe rogan the fda
warned people against taking it
skrace the director of new mexico's
department of health has previously
expressed concern about pseudoscientific
messaging about the drug which is
approved for human and vet use against
unrelated conditions the state's poison
control center reported last week calls
related to ivermectin tripled compared
to 2020
different than the than the previous
report of doubling that i mentioned
um
veterinary this is also an important
detail veteran veterinary formulations
are not approved for human use under any
conditions because the drug is often
highly concentrated for animals and the
medications include ingredients not
approved for human use so that's
ivermectin in new mexico
next
we have a new one now
hydrogen peroxide vapor yes